turn on the telly cozy up with some
popcorn and get ready for primetime
executive time tonight as president
Trump delivers the State of the Union
which some conservatives despise but
I've come to really enjoy we will
analyze then Andy millennial steps by to
give his perspective on the state of the
nation you know as a millennial as well
as to discuss Ariana Grande's botched
Japanese tattoo I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
tonight is the State of the Union the
night that libertarians despise and I
sort of enjoy especially when Donald
Trump is the one giving it we'll get to
that in a second we'll get to why some
people on the right don't like the State
of the Union but first let's make a
little money honey with selectquote Oh
selectquote is so good listen if you
have a family who depends on you then
you need to get some life insurance life
insurance can pay off a mortgage it can
help send the kids to college it's peace
of mind think you can't afford it
chances are selectquote can get you get
it for you for less than a dollar a day
now how does it do that at comparison
shops up to ten highly rated companies
including Prudential banner life and
Mutual of Omaha and others to find you
the company with the best rates for
example selectquote can find you a 35
year old man a $500,000 policy for less
than $19 a month or a 37 year old female
a 3/4 million dollar policy for under
$22 a month that is less than $1 a day a
cup of coffee costs much more than that
significantly more these days make sure
you do it be responsible give yourself
peace of mind help out your family this
is really important I made sure that
when I settle down you know little old
me my bachelor days behind me when I
settle down I made sure to get life
insurance it's really important it
really gives you peace of mind
selectquote could save you time and
money so get your free quote at select
quote comm slash Anolis KO wles today
select quote dot-com / knowles for your
free quote don't put off protecting your
family another day select quote calm /
knowles get full details on the example
policy it's electrolytic calm / knowles
your premium can vary depending on your
health issue encompasses not available
in all states probably my quote would
not be great today because my health is
not sounding too good but it's alright
because later on we're gonna be watching
the State of the Union and smoking
stogies for three hours that'll probably
help my cough and my little health the
State of the Union is a terrific
experience I have to break with some of
my fellow right-wingers and
conservatives here I really enjoy it so
some some conservatives hate it it's
basically libertarians who hate it
because they feel it's too minar kacal
it's too grandiose you know they just
want the government to leave them alone
basically disappear they view the
President as
different from any other government
office and so they just want to ignore
it and you know Antonin Scalia felt this
way too Antonin Scalia the late great
Justice refused to go he thought it was
such a ridiculous parade so plenty of
conservatives don't like it or at least
libertarians I think conservatives have
a good deal of reason to enjoy it though
for one it fulfills a requirement of the
Constitution constitutional article 2
section 3 says quote the President shall
from time to time give to the Congress
information of the State of the Union
and recommend to their consideration
such measures as he shall judge
necessary and expedient he may on
extraordinary occasions convene both
houses or either of them and in case of
disagreement between them with respect
to the time of adjournment he may have
joined them to such time as he shall
think proper he shall receive
ambassadors and other public ministers
he shall take care that the laws be
faithfully executed and show commission
all the officers of the United States so
that's the whole block that we get the
State of the Union from and really we
only get it from that first little line
up there I think there's a modern
misconception especially on the right
that the state of the union is some
wholly modern invention it was just
invented by Woodrow Wilson and that
isn't true George Washington delivered
the first State of the Union address
before the White House existed he
delivered one and then Jefferson
discontinued the practice so the third
president discontinued it and it's
because Jefferson was a Democrat
lowercase D he felt it was too minar
kacal he was an anti federalist and
which then led to the Jeffersonian
Democrats he thought it was dreadful and
I think his reasoning was not so great
but we'll get to that in a second then
for a very long time for over a hundred
years no one did it until Woodrow Wilson
so you've got Jefferson good then or I'm
sorry George Washington gives it that's
good Jefferson doesn't give it that's
probably a mark in favor of the State of
the Union and then Woodrow Wilson gives
it so that's a mark against the State of
the Union Woodrow Wilson one of the
worst presidents in American history but
then Warren Harding a highly underrated
president was the first president to
broadcast it on radio so he gives it
good old Republican limited broadcast
but nevertheless then Calvin Coolidge
it's harder to find any small more small
government conservative than Calvin
Coolidge silent Cal he gave it and he
actually was the first to broadcast the
State of the Union to the entire nation
I think he's also the only president to
actually shrink the government so I
think small government conservatives can
take a little solace there Coolidge
broadcast it from coast to coast and
then President Ronald Reagan was the
first ever to delay the State of the
Union speech so President Trump again
following in good stead by delaying the
speech for the government shutdown
President Trump obviously has fallen
followed in President Reagan steps a lot
of the time the reason that the State of
the Union I think is not only tolerable
but actually somewhat important is that
the executive is not just the DMV the
executive is not just the post office or
the IRS the executive is the president
in particular as the head of the
executive branch is representing the
spirited part of government so our
framers were very brilliant when they
set up the government this brilliant
system of checks and balances complex
system that allows a balance of power
between the people and the states and
the federal government between the
judiciary and the executive and the
legislature and all of those parts of
the government reflect different aspects
of human nature they reflect the
tripartite soul the ethos the pathos and
the logos the appetite the pathos the
spirited part the ethos and the logos
which is the reasonable part and you see
that reflected in the pathos the
appetite is the Congress it's the people
who are most directly answerable to the
appetites of the people and formerly the
appetites of the states then you have
the judiciary which is the logos they
sit in their robes they all went to the
best law schools in the country they're
very straight faced except for when they
like beer and they still like beer they
don't respond to anything at the State
of the Union they're very judicious and
then you have the president which is the
spirited part of the government he's the
one who embodies the spirit of the
country and you look to him as as one
single representative and so it seems to
me to make perfect sense to have that
representative of the spirited part of
the country show a little spirit
he's not just a bureaucrat he's
just some technocrats sitting there
filling out economic tables he's
representing something a little more
passionate and a little bit more
romantic in the government the the state
of the union is criticized by people who
lean more democratic lowercase D in
their views and we should remember the
founders and the framers were terrified
of democracy rightly so and they were
terrified of the tyranny of the majority
and also what they were terrified of was
levelling the idea that in
egalitarianism when everybody is just
exactly the same that levels everybody
down people who are more impressive
people who are more virtuous people who
have more spirit what they you can't
level people up that's not possible the
only way if you want everyone to be
exactly equal is you have to cut down
the tall trees you have to level people
down and that is necessarily so this is
what Edmund Burke the founder of modern
conservative thought saw happening in
the French Revolution he wrote this in
the famous tract reflections on the
revolution in France
it seems to me despite this silly
democratic tendency we should have
something to look up to we should have
something dignified and the State of the
Union imperfect as it is is a vessel of
that dignity the State of the Union and
really just the State of the Union as a
representative of the executive dealing
with the legislature it dignifies the
people who hold that office President
Trump in some ways does demonstrate
dignity in other way is not so much
dignity but the office can raise you up
to that you can improve over time Bill
Clinton is a good example of this even
even Lyndon Johnson was able to and he
was a depraved degenerate but he was
able to rise on occasion to a bit of
dignity and for all of us who are the
people of this country it's good to look
up to that we are not simply automat ons
we're not I mean this is the mistake of
libertarianism or egalitarianism or a
lowercase D democratic politics taken to
their extreme they just level everybody
they make us into little robots
consumers there's nothing really
metaphysical there's nothing really
noble there's not
a sense of purpose or virtue or it's
just a little leveling in plain I think
it was caning who said all simple forms
of government are bad and I think that's
just about right and our form of
government is not simple it's not simple
at all it's about as complicated as it
can be it evolves it grows through
evolution not revolution and this
example that the executive does
something a little different than the
legislature and he has an occasion to
come in and speak to the legislature and
a lot of the time the legislature goes
and fights back and reports his plans
we're gonna see a lot of that for the
next year as Nancy Pelosi is running the
House of Representatives I think that is
just perfectly fine and speaking of the
executive part of government the
spirited part there is a bombshell
report out that President Trump spends
his day in executive time that's his
phrase it the presidential private
schedule leaped we don't know who leaked
it and the left is having a field day
here's Nicole Wallace on MSNBC give her
your teenager you'd call your mom
friends for advice about how to get him
up and out of his bedroom in the morning
away from the television off social
media and phone calls with his friends
we start with that bombshell report in
Axios a White House source turning over
dozens of Trump's private schedules
filled with hundreds of hours of
executive time over just a few months
the leak either the greatest act of
insubordination in modern political
history or the bravest act of a White
House whistleblower
either way the truth bomb has been
detonated Donald Trump doesn't do much
of anything as president the schedules
which cover nearly every working day
since the midterms show that Trump has
spent around 60% of his scheduled time
over the last three months in
unstructured executive time so what
she's saying is some of the best news
for the left president Trump doesn't do
much of anything as president you can
celebrate he's not Hitler
he's not gonna invade the Rhinelander
would take over Poland oh great he
doesn't do anything because what they
are saying is that President Trump he's
just spending 60% of his day lying
around watching Fox News actually that's
some of the most productive time he
spends we'll get to that in a second but
first let's make money honey with candid
CO
have you ever had a problem with your
teeth that you always wanted to get
fixed candid is helping people gain
confidence through accessible and
affordable orthodontic care candid makes
the process of straightening your teeth
convenient and easy by having the
customer take the process into your own
hands
candids network of highly trained
orthodontists review each and every case
and directs the entire aligner plan
straight and brighter teeth in an
average of six months and cost 65% less
than braces everything is delivered to
you White Glove customer service a
candid only uses orthodontists it makes
clear aligners that are sent directly to
your home customized specifically for
you to straighten your teeth the
aligners fix crooked teeth crowding
protrusion and gaps this used to cost a
ton of money I remember when I had
braces as a kid now you can do it the
modeling kit retails for just ninety
five dollars candidates network of
orthodontists reviews your specific case
and provides you with a 3d preview of
what your treatment will look like
treatment time is an average of six
months it will save you thousands
compared to the other guys you are one
step away from getting straighter wide
your teeth take advantage of Camden's
risk-free modeling kit guarantee plus
when you use my dedicated link candid
code on /co FFA ce o-- v f EF e you will
save 25% on your modeling kit that's
candid code comm / cough fa c lv f EF e
25% off the price your modeling kit can
encode outcomes Glasgow Feb a so
executive time 60% apparently Trump only
spends 15% of his day in meetings and
the left says this is just read for now
the Heritage Foundation pointed out that
President Trump has installed a
conservative agenda specifically the
Heritage conservative agenda faster even
than President Reagan so the idea that
he's not doing much as president is a
little weird what this really gets to is
the difference between the left and the
right as they view work and exposes they
view the world which is that for the
left if you're not in a meeting if
you're not in a structured meeting with
a lot of bureaucrats and a lot of tables
and Microsoft Excel open then you're not
doing productive work you need more
meetings and then you have to have a
meeting to set up a meeting
the trouble with meetings is that
meetings are are almost never productive
meetings to quote my priest father rut
ler or the opiate of the bureaucrat and
the left is bureaucratic President Trump
spent 60% of his time in executive time
he's managed to effect a pretty
conservative agenda in that amount of
time and what is executive time
he's calling people he's called him
foreign leaders he's tweeting he's
taking in the news we need unstructured
time you don't you don't really think
about the big picture when you're in a
meeting with a bunch of bureaucrats
around you you think about it when
you're driving around when you're going
you've got an hour in between meetings
you're walking to the airport I don't
know that is unstructured time that
really helps the left did this to Ronald
Reagan Ronald Reagan famously would end
work at six o'clock he said if I see an
executive who can't finish his work in
eight or nine hours I see an ineffective
executive and Ronald Reagan another one
of the great effective conservative
presidents so great job if the left
really believes this good you can be at
ease he's not going to take over all of
Europe the right won't last a thousand
years because he's so lazy for the rest
of us we know that he is working in a
much more effective way than the
bureaucracy of the left we have got to
bring on we have a lot more to say about
working but we have first got to bring
on someone who obviously doesn't work
very much by virtue of his youth and
vigor and a millennial so Andy thank you
so much for coming on it's been a while
we haven't had you on in a little while
a long time yeah but you've been busy
you've been collecting a lot of
experiences so what's going on
what can you update us well you know not
much I mean we've got this State of the
Union I think it's an urgent urgent
moment of a political you know something
of urgency going on and for the country
and you know I would watch it myself if
I weren't hanging with my buds but you
know I think I'm really hoping that
important progressive agenda will be put
forward it's very very important to me
that we are progressive so what what
specifically do you want to see out of
the State of the Union I don't know a
lot about issues you know and then I
said like or facts or anything like that
but speaking as a millennial just
speaking as my lived experience as a
millennial you know I think I think I
live out my progressivism you know like
I mean you know looking you look back in
the old days and people didn't have
tattoos you know and now like I have a
tattoo on every part of my body so
that's like progress you know I made
progress and if people you
wouldn't wouldn't wear stuff that we're
afraid to wear anything like all right
but you know III have like piercings on
my nose and not putting rings in my nose
that's progress you know and like I
believe in like the environment you know
environments are like it I think we got
to get rid of all this like oil in all
these cities they're just ruining
environment bring back the jungle you
know so we can be walking through the
jungle with tattoos and I think that's
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you know sacrificing babies I think
we've got like children we make them
look we're living in Apocalypto with
this we are that's right we so the State
of Union addresses tonight you are I
have to tell you you are the most
articulate millennial spokesman that
I've ever is amazing it's amazing for a
man my age have a grasp of the language
this extensive it can only be attributed
to hard study and this I think it just
comes in through this a fact that's what
it comes in through hard study the
legalization of shrooms and I do you
have you touched on this tattoo question
yes did you see this story about your
fellow melenik ariana grande she got a
tattoo for her new song she has a song
called seven rings yeah she got a tattoo
for some reason in Japanese and she got
it for some reason on the palm of her
hand but it turns out that the tattoo
doesn't say seven rings in Japanese it
says barbeque grill
well I'm very supportive of barbecue you
like that's right I'm into myself I get
anything wings and ribs this is I
actually can't make a joke about this
because that is the joke I mean this is
the idea that these little white
millennial girls are getting Japanese
tattooed on their wrist and they think
it means water and really it is like you
know we'll try what is this you know I
was watching the Super Bowl and
room 5 guy what's his name Adam Levine
he takes off his shirt and like every
inch of his body is tattooed you just
think like you know I got 20 years it's
gonna look really really bad I mean like
look at Schwarzenegger you know the way
what happens to your body after all yeah
that's mr. universe
yeah the strongest men in the world you
know it is funny I I have to tell you
Alyssa Milano though is part of a very
very weird you look at her she dresses
like a little girl yeah he noticed this
but that yeah but she's hot you know I
mean she's already very people it's it's
a weird little thing we're having in our
rock and our rock idols at the moment
III don't really understand where it
comes from I have an inkling because
it's not just these stars
it's Millennials broadly are so much
more tatted up than other generations
they all have tattoos and I mean I have
seen people on their kneecaps they'll
have giant citrus fruit yeah one kneecap
in the other and just random little
designs that don't seem to mean anything
you know I was kidding around when we
started but it really does seem to me
that certain things that were considered
primitive like the idea that you were
primitive was not a good thing you know
trying to be civilized we're gonna move
forward trying to move that but certain
things that were considered primitive
like all these piercings and things that
you've seen in native cultures and the
tattoos they actually are coming back I
don't think it's a good thing I think
we're actually like that trajectory up
out of the jungle I think is a good one
I think that's what the kind of one we
want to stick with that you know like
less killing less beating up women this
thing's like that and there used to be
specific times to get a tattoo for
instance if you're in the Marines or
you're a criminal and you're you wake up
with a tattoo you're right remember
that's actually to be encouraged yeah
yeah cuz you do a you actually I suppose
for our criminals and and also for our
service members for obviously very
different reasons those are two groups
where strength really matters yes we're
a sort of the niceties of civilization
really kind of have to go away one if
you're trying to protect people and
fight for the good guy isn't to if
you're making your way through prison
right now it's all of these little
hipster guys who weigh 120 pounds no and
they were leggings all day long it
really is strange and it is this harking
but you know this Steven Pinker is kind
of he's kind of a liberal I wouldn't
call him like a far lefty or anything
like this but he does like this because
he's a scientist or he does like to say
things that kind of make the left crazy
like men and women are different I mean
all the science shows that you know
women heard him and one of the things he
has he talked about he's been talking
about it for a long time
is that the world has gotten less
violent as it has become more civilized
obviously our wars are so horrific
because we have so much these engines of
destruction but if you live in a
uncivilized society and primitive
society are more likely to get killed or
raped than you are now and in this
incredible you know world that we have
why these kids who have never been to
war or who have never most of them said
they took the way they talk the way
Alexandria occasional cortex talks do
you think she has never left New York I
mean she is never but only the really
nice part we're not talking about but
they've never seem to have been anyway
and yet and yet they are bedecked with
this kind of like you know stuff in
their skin and I don't mean to just be
just dismiss it because like believe me
my generation if we had thought a
piercing our faces we would have
certainly occurred as we were so stoned
out of our minds yeah but so it's not
like just saying oh this is me it's it's
the particular message that's sending
this message that like that we're going
backwards you know you know where I
think it comes from a little bit too is
this postmodern nihilism because the
tattoos are not often significant if I I
will make an exception if someone has a
really significant tattoo and they wine
theirs they have really good reasons for
I sort of can understand that I was at
an Apple store in Grand Central and the
guy who was helping me out on his ring
finger had a little moustache tattoo and
then on the middle finger it said s a
word for fecal matter
krei in cursive okay stuff cray yeah
short for crazy
yeah that's meaningless that is not that
is the embodiment of meaninglessness and
you see an women to have these crazy
tattoos where it's just like a little
squiggle
yeah or just a random little shape all
down their body I think they're it's
because we are saying nothing really
matters and
thing really matters to me why not I'm
just a big hunk of flesh and there is
also in this oppression matrix that
we've created that you know the
intersectionality ideology the one thing
that unites all of these disparate
groups that seem to contradict one
another is that they hate
Big Daddy Western civilization uh-huh
and so I mean from the time of Rousseau
certainly up to the present you have
this romantic idea of the primitive of
the savage of the jungle and I think on
a certainly unconscious level when we're
talking about Millennials I think that's
what that's getting at a little bit just
you can't make me conform man
well think about it I think about the
fact that they've made these movies
avatar
Pocahontas Dances with Wolves are all
the same movie a civilized man goes back
into a more backward culture and finds
that that is where truth is that's where
you know honesty and integrity are and
there's always and the women are always
treated well because the you know
primitive cultures women are not treated
well and it really is interesting when
you watch avatar was the one that always
got me because they have everything that
you would have if you had oil but they
have it by magic laughter they have
lights but they had a little plants that
light up and they can fly around yeah
and then they fire on the Dragons ah
yeah
let's make a little money honey and as
the Catholic of The Daily wire I think
it only makes sense that I should sell
indulgences Valentine's Day is fast
approaching what are you gonna do it's
the age-old dilemma if you go to your
local flower shop you look especially
you get close to the day you're probably
gonna get ripped off I think I bought
dandelions for like $400 last year don't
do that sometimes they're not fresh
chocolate you know you can't eat that
you're fat don't make yourself fat and
you throw out the whole box this year do
something original and indulgent for
Valentine's something that rings the
bell indulgences dot store not calm
indulgences dad's store together with
halo healthy tribes indulgences dustur
is partnered to create an indulgent line
of hot beverage mixes just add water for
some of the most sumptuous mugs of hot
cocoa and other flavors there's mazaru
matcha yogi goji Oh hubba hubba I'm
already getting hot just thinking about
it pink velvet whole lot sale oven I
can't read anymore it's just too good
the taste is spectacular and they're
filled with spectacular stuff
hundred-percent natural no added sugar
superfoods cocoa MCT oil collagen
prebiotic inulin chia seed I don't even
know what
things are but they sound very healthy
check it out
they're really good these these good
foods have advantages relative to other
fats because they bypass the small
intestine and are metabolized directly
into the body by the liver creating
instant energy that sounds really good
especially when you got a liver like
mine these indulgent beverages are
available in Valentine's Day gift
packages starting as low as 39 bucks but
step up and be a man indulge her with
six flavors were save even more enroll
her in the subscription program to get
12 additional flavors over the next year
act now get ahead of the valentine's
crunch there's a special deal just for
my listeners enter co v a co v fe f e at
checkout save 10% act quickly save money
get Valentine's Day covered with a gift
she will appreciate that lasts and is
enjoyed for months indulgences dot store
promo code offa CoV f EF e 10% savings
indulgences doubt stored on screwed up
input com indulgences that store state
of the union's gonna be on tonight yep
we're gonna be watching and other than
progress what are you looking for well I
mean I think it is interesting he's been
talking about they've been talking about
a call for unity which is just a really
fascinating idea to me because Donald
Trump in many ways erase all the
attitudinal stuff all the tweets and the
insults and all those things that's the
style that people love and hate I don't
want to erase no but at the moment yeah
they're stipulated salawah Donald Trump
is a very practical guy I mean he wants
things to work and I've always noticed
this about him that he wants he's a
narcissist and so he wants to be loved
but he wants to be loved for fixing
stuff he said it again and again I fix
things that's what I do you know and
he's actually taken that approach I mean
nothing he's done has been ideological
except in the sense that the left has
given him no room to move so he's only
been able to move to the right that's
the only way he's been able to go but
he's perfectly you hear him when he
negotiates like yeah I give you the
dreamers and I'll take the wall the
dreamers let all the criminals out of
prison yeah whatever you know he
actually has no ideology whatsoever I
think most Americans were like that I do
not think I think people like us have an
ideology most Americans just wants to
fix
why isn't this working why can't I get
to work why can't I do this stuff and so
it is interesting if it weren't for his
effect he would actually probably be a
uniting figure as it is he has made his
personality such a big part of his
presidency that
I think he's in this battle locked in
this battle with Nancy Pelosi who I
seriously think for all she's a highly
professional politician and a real
killer I think she can't let go of the
battle I do believe you know I think
Trump Trump actually you know he gets
personal but he'd give her a lot of what
she wants she can't she can't because he
he can let go of the battle so much as
people smear Lindsey Graham called him
all sorts of all names he called all of
the other Republicans awful names and
now they're buddies he goes down to my
Texas for Ted Cruz says I know he used
to be lyin Ted now he's beautiful too I
love it what I said he really doesn't
say before Sir against and and I just
think it is interesting that if you
could just look at his policies just
look at his approach he would be a
unifying figure but he's not you know
right and I think and I think that
that's really interesting because I
think if you if you look he's the
opposite of Obama who had a kind of
appealing quieter style but did things
that actually tore the country in pieces
and we're deeply any longer deeply
ideological and so he's the kind of the
opposite of that but I really do believe
that he and Pelosi are in a battle royal
they should none of them that he can
move because this base will follow him
right but she can't because her her base
is actually not following her it's
following a ideology and I love that
idea if he had a different personality
he's being if I had some ham I could
have a ham sandwich
if I had some ground well it'll be a lot
of fun tonight it's true it will be fun
except boring as hell I think yeah well
at least you know I've got this little
throat yeah so I'll be able to work
through that with all those good cigars
that's the important thing those cigars
will cure you right up and though will
bury them yeah Andy millennial good to
see you I will shake your hand on
account of but I'll see you in a few
hours I'll be there all right we've got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
if you are on daily we're calm thank you
you helped keep the lights on you keep
COFA a in my cup if not head over there
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get Andy
millennial you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get the amount Walter you get to ask
questions in the mailbag that's coming
up Thursday get your questions in you
get to ask questions backstage that's
coming up in a few hours get subscribed
get those questions ready you get
another Kingdom to get everything and
you get this you get the little
President Trump is gonna have what is it
going to be an hour tonight an hour and
a half of saying whatever he wants and
all those Democrat they're gonna it's
gonna be like that picture of Chuck and
Nancy the American Gothic it's gonna be
that turned up to 11
get your tumblr go to Daley wire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
I do want to finish this thought on
executive time and how we work and what
work really means I mean you know the
left the left attacks Donald Trump for
opposite reasons they attack him for
being too effective and right-wing and
awful and terrible and they attack him
for being lazy and not doing anything
and just watching Fox News all day and
they it can't be both they've obviously
come to a conclusion and they're in
search of an argument but the way the
president Trump works 60% executive time
15% meetings one I think that's a pretty
good idea and two I think it's pretty
emblematic of our time and the way that
we work these days you know there is a
study that just came out about half of
Americans consider themselves
workaholics 48% consider themselves
workaholics they have on average 7 point
5 hours of screen time daily this makes
sense a lot of us are on our screens for
work and if you're not on your screen a
lot for work you're maybe you're on some
screen or you're obviously using screens
and all your personal life what does it
mean to be a workaholic it's not the
people who are in the coal mines for 18
hours a day what they mean is that they
worry about work on a day that they're
off what it means is that this is just
how they described it they feel too busy
to take a vacation ever
it means that the minute they wake up
they're on their phone they're checking
email there right away logged on a 58%
of respondents say that they do that I
certainly do that they they say that
these are the top three symptoms of
workaholic ISM does this mean that we're
working harder all the time no actually
it doesn't but what it means is that
we're almost never not working I mean I
say this as a man who sleeps 27 hours a
day you know I'm not working like
grinding away at the coal mine all day
long but I am always sort of working
it's very rare that I'm not working I
don't think I'm the only one I think
most people are they're checking emails
in the old days you would have business
hours and then after business hours you
wouldn't really be bothered
now what's business hours I get calls
all through the night I make calls all
through the night I expect people to
pick up on the East Coaster on the west
coast president from his emblematic of
this he's always sort of
working so when he's watching Fox and
Friends and tweeting that is obviously
that's work he's gaining information
he's pushing his agenda he's in one of
his biggest roles he's a spokesman he's
a communicator that's maybe the chief
charge of the president as a political
figure and that that doesn't have
business errors the modern economy
doesn't have business hours so you know
there are some proposals now I just read
it one of them where a few companies are
giving women over 30 time off to date
you think this is ridiculous what it
ridiculous idea these Millennials are so
coddled whatever I actually think it's a
pretty good idea because what it makes
us aware of is the the one moral hazard
of our economy of our work hard free
markets capitalist American economy
which is so wonderful the one hazard is
that we lose perspective and we think
that we're just economic creatures were
just automatic ensue MERS whatever but
really life is so much more than that we
are that's one aspect of what we do but
we only do that to serve ourselves so we
have higher aims than just buying a lot
of nice stuff we have relationships and
duties and responsibilities to our
families to our communities and to our
God we have a purpose in our life beyond
just consuming the nicest electronics
and in this economy it's especially I've
lived in New York and LA it's really
hard for people to date because they're
working all the time and so I think this
actually in a kind of silly way is
addressing that problem and more
executive time is if that's the way of
the American economy of so be it I mean
that's that's good and we can be more
effective that way and if private
solutions are coming around to trying to
get a little bit more of a balance in
life and try to make you see that life
is about more than just chugging away on
Excel spreadsheets or something I think
that's a that's a good move too we have
to get to Nancy Pelosi's Bible quote did
you if you didn't see this Nancy Pelosi
has been using this quote from the Bible
Nancy Pelosi is a self-described
Catholic of course she has a radical
abortion agenda she but she at least
says that she's a Catholic Andrew Cuomo
who legalized infanticide what two weeks
ago he said so he's a Catholic too
Nancy Pelosi has been giving this little
stump speech for years and years where
she quotes a line of the Bible there's
just one problem I can't find it in the
Bible but I use I quoted all the time
and I keep reading and reading the Bible
I know what's there someplace it's
supposed to be in Isaiah but I heard
Bishops say to minister to the needs of
God's creation is an act of worship to
ignore those needs is to dishonor the
God who made us it's there somewhere in
some words or another but certainly the
Spirit of it is there it's there
somewhere it's got to be that's God I
know it's it's supposed to be in Isaiah
oh really did Isaiah you should take
that up with him Isaiah promised you it
was going to be there it's supposed to
be there I mean it's not it isn't there
or anywhere else in the Bible but Nancy
Pelosi the Gospel according to st. Nancy
of the of Sacramento or of wherever that
she insists that it's there but it's not
it's not there the quote that she's
using is the Bible tells us in the Old
Testament to minister to the needs of
God's creation as an act of worship to
ignore those needs is to dishonor the
God who made us what Nancy Pelosi is
doing is an act of worship it is an act
of self worship that's what she's doing
she's saying listen I know that this is
in the Bible I know that this is what
the Bible tells us I mean it doesn't and
it's not anywhere in the Bible but I
want it to be and so I will turn the
scripture the Word of God to what I want
this is an analogy that is used for this
sometimes is looking down a well I have
no doubt that Nancy Pelosi has read the
Bible on some occasions in her life
skimmed it at least and what we do when
we just skim the Bible for our own
purposes without any sort of
interpretive Doctrine without any sort
of people teaching it to us going
through it with us guiding us
spiritually through it what it's like is
it's like looking down a dark well a
profound and dark well and all you see
is your own reflection in the water
that's what Nancy Pelosi is doing she's
looking at the Bible whatever she
skimmed and she's seeing her own reflect
and so it couldn't possibly be the case
that that quote is not in the Bible it
has to be because Nancy said so and what
is the quote the quote is to minister to
the needs of creation as an act of
worship no that would be idolatrous to
worship the creation is idolatry now too
to be a we have stewardship over the the
earth we have dominion over the earth
that's our job that's the duty that God
gave to us worship is worship we worship
God we don't worship the creation we're
not supposed to worship ourselves this
is the trouble with being lightly
educated you know what's the little
learning is a dangerous thing this is
the trouble with only reading books of
quotations or only reading quotation
memes on the internet there's that
famous meme that's a picture of Abraham
Lincoln it says don't believe everything
you read on the Internet
Abraham Lincoln 1862 and I like books of
quotations Winston Churchill I believe
recommended books of quotations to
people he had some of the great book
quotations in all of those modern books
actually speaking of Churchill I was in
a dinner with a fairly well-known
actress and we were having dinner
left-wing and this actress said we were
discussing Winston Churchill she said
you know Churchill said during the
Second World War that Parliament was
about to cut funding to the arts and
Winston Churchill said then what are we
fighting for of course he didn't say
that
I knew this immediately because I know
anything about Winston Churchill Winston
Churchill did not fight the Second World
War and fighting the Boer War II didn't
escape from a prison camp in South
Africa he didn't do all of that to
preserve government funding for stupid
plays that often are terrible and bad
modern murals he I promise you he didn't
do that
as I know something about Winston
Churchill so I just know that that isn't
true but what people do is they look
down that well at whatever profound
issue they're looking at and they only
see their own reflection I was I forget
I was tweeting about something the other
day on the internet and some dummy blue
checkmark guy
tried to make some point but it wasn't a
very good point and but because he
didn't seem terribly intelligent and he
didn't seem terribly humble he he
couldn't understand that his point had
been refuted so I used a line from the
Bock a by Euripides which is talk talk
sense to a fool and he calls you foolish
it's useless to talk sense to a fool and
then he responded with a quote from
Oscar Wilde that said that quotations
are a substitute for wit and I said I
know Oscar Wilde didn't say that and I
looked it up and that quotation is not
true either we have we're in this very
shallow culture we're in a very glib
culture where we are quoting all of
these great ideas great thinkers we are
pretending that we are following in a
long intellectual tradition and we're
not we are severing ourselves from that
tradition because we are not being
cultured and we're not being educated
and what we are doing is just
substituting a false fantasy of that
tradition and everyone else who's also
uneducated and uncultured thinks that
that's true what requires what is
required to fix this is humility we
actually can't just tell the left you
guys are a bunch of idiots we I mean we
can maybe you know once every so often
we can say that but what we need is a
little humility too because even us on
the right we are not well educated this
is just a symptom of the 20th and 21st
centuries our education systems have
been destroyed K through 12 college and
graduate school they've been really
hollowed out by ideology by leftism by
trying to look down the profound well of
our tradition and only seeing ourselves
only seeing the perpetual present this
is a really big issue I want to be
speaking at UCLA tomorrow I'll be giving
a lecture on a similar topic so if
you're around go check it out before we
go I also have to get to the Super Bowl
I know I didn't watch the Super Bowl I
was on an airplane apparently no one
else watched it either though so I don't
feel that bad
I suppose it happened this was the
lowest moment of the trump presidency if
we I'm sorry I'm sorry that I even have
to watch this would you let your son
Barron play football
it's very it's very tough question it's
a very good question if he wanted to yes
would I steer him that way no I wouldn't
why I wouldn't and he actually plays a
lot of soccer he's liking soccer and a
lot of people including me thought
soccer would probably never make it in
this country but it really is moving
forward rapidly I just don't like the
reports that I see coming out having to
do with football I mean it's a dangerous
sport and I think it's you know it's
really tough I thought the equipment
would get better and it has the helmets
have gotten far better but it hasn't
solved the problem so you know I hate to
say it because I love to watch football
I think the NFL is a great product but I
really think that as far as myself well
I've heard NFL players saying they
wouldn't let their sons play football so
it's not totally unique but I would have
a hard time with it I don't even
disagree with much of what he said but
that soccer line Baron plays soccer mr.
president please I you know that I care
about you your office your family seems
lovely
the soccer please don't what good is it
if we secure our border we deport
illegal alien criminals we get our
economy moving again we make America
what good is that what does that avail
if American children are playing soccer
what's the point what then are we
fighting for to quote not Winston
Churchill really said the future of
football is in question I don't care
because I don't watch football and I
like baseball and I think baseball is a
much more sophisticated sport and more
enjoyable to watch and I think football
is very boring and it's especially
boring during that Super Bowl where they
score two combined to 16 points but
we're looking at the lowest rated Super
Bowl ever low 10-year low we're looking
at a few reasons for this part of it is
TV people aren't watching linear linear
TV anymore but of course they can stream
it on any device they want part of that
is the growing popularity of other
sports like soccer part of it is
politics part of it is get woke go broke
the NFL came in and embraced Colin
Kaepernick let all of those ingrates on
the
field make a mockery of our country and
make a mockery of the sport they
tolerated it they encouraged it that
incompetent football commissioner did it
and now look what has happened and that
now in a door there was supposed to be
run during the Super Bowl
from CBS was shut down for being too
political in the other direction don't
ask if your loyalty is crazy ask if your
loyalty is crazy enough when they
question you running towards danger for
those who are unable or unwilling when
they laugh at the thought of you
willingly sacrificing your life for
someone you may never know stay that way
some people think you're crazy being
loyal defending the Constitution
standing for the flag then I guess I'm
crazy then I guess I'm crazy then I
guess I'm crazy
and for those who kneel they fail to
understand that they can kneel and that
they can protest that they can despise
what I stand for even hate the truth
that I speak but they can only do that
because I am crazy enough great
commercials from nine line which I
believe is a Vette owned company in
normal America Colin Kaepernick would be
ostracized Nike would not be allowed to
advertise and this company would be
doing great and today it's the opposite
that spells trouble not just for the NFL
about which I don't care at all but for
the country we'll have to see what
happens tonight at the State of the
Union in the meantime I'll see in a few
hours in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
of era production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19